for the last three years Chef Ramsay has
whipped aspiring chefs into shape on
Hell's Kitchen this is painful get out
for Ramsey the most successful
restaurateur on the planet with
critically acclaimed restaurants in
London Dubai Tokyo and New York is
crisscrossing America for the most
difficult assignment of his career this
is disgusting I am gobsmacked turning
around America's Kitchen Nightmares
please help me each week he will go to
restaurants on the brink of disaster
there is no more money he's not doing
his job this place is a disaster Zone
put so much into it but to get these
restaurants back on track Chef Ramsay
will hold nothing back I've never ever
ever
met someone
I believe in as little as you it will be
peace you dirty Pig what do we need a
death in the restaurant before some
[__] gets the grip I thought your food
was crap I'd rather have this
conversation downstairs it will be
emotional
seriously I'm pissed off it's not my
fault why did you keep eating if it was
that bad
and it will be shocking fire them in a
spot oh my God look at them it's [__]
rancid it's rotten I've eaten it I've
been like speeding on both of them I
think this place will run better without
you can you go and tell them that the
kitchen is closed we're shut is the
luckiest day of their lives we're shirt
for the night
we will make this a success put your
hand up and swear to God in the end you
will see dramatic turnarounds aren't
they horrible
[Music]
but not just the restaurants
but the people who work in them
you're the best man and while most
appreciate his help God bless you you
are a wonderful person others aren't so
grateful
Jeff I know you can hear me don't run
what is this guy here who the [__] are
you to turn around and tell me when you
were like a pig French Pig goodbye Chef
good luck loser
get ready as Chef Ramsay turns America's
Kitchen Nightmares do you go four guys
received may the Lord not kill me with
food poisoning back into dreams please
do not screw it up
tonight on Kitchen Nightmares one of
Long Island's most historical and
successful restaurants has become a
local disaster it's in a dumpster now
this place is falling apart there's a
stink in this place so bad and the
owners a mother and her son he's looking
for a man you are going to apologize
if Chef Ramsay can't help me it's done
Gordon has one week to turn it around
what am I doing wrong touch the wall you
dirty Pig but face is an extremely
uphill battle you kill whatever
customers we got left the head chef is
arrogant let him do what he wants the
sous chef doesn't care whatever the
waitresses are disorganized is that
yours or mine Diane this is mine and the
kitchen this is disgusting it's the
dirtiest kitchen Gordon has ever seen
look at that you didn't see that I
didn't see it I've eaten it how will
Gordon return the Seascape to its former
glory you're running a business and if
you don't want to run it as a business
[__] close it get ready for some
drastic measures nothing's been choked
in here this evening we're going down
now tonight
on Kitchen Nightmares
[Music]
Islip New York rich with history and
Community spirit
but a crown jewel of this seaside
village the Seascape Inn is on the verge
of collapse
the owners are a mother named Irene and
a son named Peter if you can't put them
in a dining room tell them to shut the
[__] up tell him to get out of here it's
a big deal close the [__] doors if
you don't like him
the Seascape has been around since 1962.
we've been declare the oldest the
restaurant in the town of Islip in the
Glory Days at the Seascape my father he
was here when they were doing 300 covers
on a Saturday night and the place was
alive and everybody was smiling
making money there was love everywhere
and you could feel it when you walked
into the Seascape
I started to work here at the Seascape
in 1967. it was buzzing you wouldn't
believe the amount of customers we had
on Saturday night they'd actually stand
online outside the door
the restaurant it's in the dumpster now
[Music]
I don't even like to tell people I work
here anymore there's a lot of
contributing factors of why you know
people don't come back we've had
complaints about that sewage smell
there was a stink in this place so bad
and I can't believe anybody came in at
all
Maybe the reason why the restaurant has
gone down in the last past two years
Chef Doug is not listening to a word I
say doesn't make a difference if I want
to serve them now that's what I want to
serve them I've been doing this 38 years
I went to The Culinary Institute of
America I worked in successful
restaurants world renowned I like having
the command in the kitchen anybody's got
a problem with it they can come to me
I'm going to say my piece wherever I go
to whoever I meet doesn't matter their
status I really don't care don't serve
it in that that's all you got to do it's
that simple Doug's loud and obnoxious
you want a rock let's rock he's crazy
my father he was a Hands-On in the
kitchen I was always the guy that was
out front and two years ago my father
passed away
after he passed away it did hurt us
the rug is being pulled out from under
me and I got to do something about it I
need 800 to a million dollars to save
the Seascape I don't want my doors to
close but what am I doing wrong Chef
Ramsay is My Last Hope because if Chef
Ramsay can't help me it's done
I'm not wasting more time
this building is 105 years old when this
restaurant first opened 40 years ago it
was a hot spot in town now it's at the
bottom I'm starting to understand why
what is that pile of [__] there
gone
oh God good morning good morning how are
you how you doing and first name sorry
Peter Peter Gordon good to see you miss
I threw me off didn't realize how tall
he was does make you a little bit more
intimidating Mom this is Gordon Ramsay
nice it's a pleasure to meet you not so
I was very impressed with him very
handsome very tall blonde good looking
actually if it was like 20 years ago I
would have said you know what we connect
this is uh the veteran waitress Marilyn
wow who's been here since the beginning
and when you say beginning how long have
you been here well I really saw it in
1967. 67. right I was born then maybe
except Ray I'm just gonna tell me I just
shouldn't be here I'm too old and I'd
respect him if he said that I'll be out
the door and this is Chef Doug Doug how
are you very nice mini skirt there what
is that an apron yeah oh this is oh okay
yeah nice that's my wiping work that's
your wiping rack Gordon Ramsay coming
here to me it's a slap in the face
let's go in the dining room let's go
let's have a blast all right okay you
run the place and your mum assists you
yes yes describe Seascape for me it's a
Titanic
it was a luxury liner and it's sinking I
see it as a very poorly run restaurant
that's the last time she gave me a
compliment because you just don't listen
and that's why Compliments are very hard
to come by
girls right now I'm hungry I want to
taste the food and let's meet after
shall we absolutely is there anything
else that I need to know before I start
eating the Border Health came here and
believe me they gave us 95 so the place
is clean right where should I go for uh
[Music]
thank you you're so welcome I was
excited uh little butterflies in the
stomach I'm gonna be insulted by the
best chef in the world
there's a really bad smell in here
sewage
[Music]
I can't believe people come in here
okay I'm gonna start off with the um
crab cakes please okay I like the idea
of the pesto Lobster ravioli I'll go for
the Atlantic salmon blackened please
call me a pig okay I'm hungry
yeah well at least she's honest the
place stinks I think this place
who's this
that's Chef Ramsay okay no problem uh
one order of crab cakes
[Music]
this place is falling apart
let's hope the food's good oh hey can we
crab cakes
[Music]
I'll see everywhere
come on
okay just falls apart I've been like the
decor if you touch it it just
disintegrates then I'm fresh
they've got it wrong on the menu it's
crab cake it's a crab cake
because I feel if I eat any more I'll be
crapping for the next 105 years
are they frozen I don't think so did you
want something for me sure it tastes
Frozen okay thank you
Doug you make the crab cakes here right
yes are they frozen I freeze them yeah
he says they taste like they're frozen
that's all really yeah [__] off
[Applause]
they are frozen
time
more parsley
[Music]
soggy
strange taste inside they're definitely
not fresh uh on that occasion salmon you
want you still want the sauteed spinach
and the pesto or yeah
[Music]
what is that that is pesto is it good
well it's just all separated
it looks like an oil slick yeah it's
never on the side it's usually served on
the fish when I served in the salmon he
did have something to say about the
pesto sauce it was painted
so to speak
solid inside and dry and
God
you can't expect customers to come and
pay for that [__]
you definitely have to dry my my
homemade Greek cookies and I basically
you're gonna say you never had a better
one oh Chef Ramsay he's a lot like me I
love him when you eat that cookie you
lift it up and you buy it
foreign
[Music]
he just choked on your mother's cookie
I mean I don't have an answer I don't
[Music]
before Gordon passes on his comments to
the chef and the owners he decides to
observe a dinner service to get a more
complete picture of the problems in the
restaurant
a New England clam chowder smells fishy
[Music]
yeah it's a little cold
I'm telling you the truth it's cold it
is cold this is so sad so [__] sad
with customers complaining in the
restaurant Gordon looks to the owner to
solve the problems sir like I said if
you think I scam do me a favor do what
you gotta do but I would say one thing
before you make the phone call not in
from the customers get in here
[__] it now my God
oh my after being disappointed with the
front of the house it was time to check
out the engine room of the restaurant
the kitchen
dog yeah he said this is cold and feel
the plate it is cold
no it's not cold it's not
he plays a stone cold
the plate was cold would you take it out
Diane yeah you would they put it up I
take it [__] me no it's all right
I don't worry about it
[Music]
what's your fascination will pass you on
the plate
I I just happened the way like The
Parsley looks to be honest with you
it stinks it's dried parsley it's a sign
of a dated Russian sprinkle it on your
wife but not on the [__] place you
mean I like the way I cook it doesn't
like the way I cook that's his opinion
oops oh God
[Music]
why aren't they cleaning it
this is extraordinary
stop there come here how [__] can you
walk past that [__] pay them to work in
it
I mean he just spilled a buck a bucket
of [__] tomato sauce
why can't you say something to him about
cleaning up his mess
Chef dog is not listening to a word I
say but sometimes I'm not in the mood
what is going on oh no he's got a mop
[Music]
Peter Peter one second did you hear what
I said I heard you I didn't ask you to
go mop up their [__]
that's not the right answer bud
What a Sad [__]
oh can I clean it now
while Peter cleans up the mess on the
floor
when was the last time this place was
clean Gordon realizes that this is part
of a bigger problem
oh my God coming up this is disgusting
Gordon gets up early to investigate you
kill whatever customers we got left but
what he finds makes him wish he'd never
gotta look at that you didn't see that I
didn't see it I've eaten it and owners
Peter and Irene suffer the consequences
I'm closing it down nothing's been
killed in here this evening on Kitchen
Nightmares
foreign
[Music]
comes in to prepare for lunch Gordon
arrives early to do a thorough
investigation of the kitchen
oh God
what is that twice by potato thank [__]
I missed that one twice
so dirty
God when was that claimed oh my God
what is that this is ten thousand times
worse than I thought it would be
it's like lava
of [__] and crap kitchen health hazard
bingo
my fresh
Lobster ravioli
strange taste inside fresh
my [__] ass I've eaten this [__] the
general hygiene
in refrigeration
oh [__] out
so that's the pesto I had for lunch
just look at the colors in there look at
that
it's moldy
[Music]
it's now lunch time the chefs are
preparing customers are getting ready to
eat but Gordon steps in he's not a good
word we're both here two seconds no
problem
when was last time you went in the
kitchen and had a little look around
once every Tuesday so we'll go in the
wall scrub them down
when was that cleaned
I mean you mentioned earlier about how
clean right this place was the water
Health came here and believe me they
gave us 95 so the place is clean that's
95 out of 100. right I really don't
think you've got any idea
can I just take you in there sure come
on let's go yeah
is that an order yeah yeah you just stop
Charles stop what you're doing yeah are
you aware how filthy your kitchen is
dare you cook me a lunch out of this
kitchen known for well how filthy your
kitchen is
see Damon walk behind the line
look at them everything come here two
seconds Peter get your [__] head
under there dog look under there why
have we got product in there why are you
using it why is it not condemned to have
another Chef in my face about my kitchen
I'm pissed off following me
futon's gone moldy oh my God would you
eat that
let's go in the walk-in free listen man
I'm amazed how I'm amazed how you're so
cool and chilled at this you know that
dog food in the fridge that's the fish
bag it's what God
actually that that was for me actually
that's for you yeah don't eat it don't
[__] eat it I already have you've
eaten it smell that then it's not sound
are you [__] mad sound on the outside
oh come on this pork
the pork was mine that's my that's my
personal meals oh [__] hell I didn't
expect this kind of a mess that I've
seen I'm very upset I mean that's the
only way to put it very disappointed
very upset what's this
that's a chicken valdostano does that
look half cooked started to be cooked
thank you
I'm just not a throwaway person that was
cooked on Friday and I had to recook it
Saturday that's what you got to do you
kill whatever customers we got left
when it comes to the freshness of the
food that really falls on just the chef
alone can we get out of here it's his
name so it's probably his fault get me
the music bowl of pesto please Charles
my main course in there yesterday you
had occasion salmon that's right what's
the sauce
the sauce was a pesto sauce bring it
over please
all right I didn't see it you didn't see
that I didn't see it you got glasses on
the mat the pesto sauce that was not
forgivable I'm humiliated about that
believe me positively positively
now this is not a Time hey to laugh and
take the [__] piss out of me I've
eaten this [__]
what's going on Peter
I'm surprised I Gordon didn't make him
eat it and this is scrubbed every
Tuesday oh [__] every [__] week you
got the nerve to tell me that you clean
the walls every [__] Tuesday [__] off
will you touch the wall your dirty Pig
this is disgusting
I'm closing it down how many's booked
about 20 20. forget it
the place steam clean from [__] head
to tail I don't care but we're not
cooking a [__] cookie out of here
Marilyn Marilyn yes sir nothing's coming
out of this kitchen okay fine when Chef
Ramsay shut down the restaurant it was
shocking of course and his face was all
red Chef Ramsay he was really upset okay
should I tell the customers outside to
leave
please
switch it off we're going down now
okay thank you for coming but the Chef
Ramsay actually he wants to open up
tomorrow all my years will never shut up
a kitchen and tell the Customs to go
home never and that's that's an
embarrassment
not here anyway
why don't you clean when you're quiet I
stay busy all day from 11 o'clock when I
walk in the door until 5 36 when we get
tables
doing preparation every day by myself
Gordon Ramsay it can go off on somebody
for absolutely no reason it's impossible
to clean everything and he just doesn't
get it what'd you find so funny Charlie
what'd you find what was funny for you
what do you want me to do stand here
start crying or something what do you
want me to do I don't know where you
want kiss your ass and say I think you
know a great job and clean on Tuesday
nights when you're [__] start on your
crack doing cockle are you gonna do
anything or are you gonna stand and
stare at me
[Music]
is that your weakness you don't know how
to run stuff no this is what they keep
telling you that's what I keep been
telling you all this time time to shut
the [__] up tell them to get out of here
close the [__] doors if you don't
like him take charge this is what he's
looking but for a man
and that's what I'm looking for you to
become
where's your fire this is your mum
where's your fight you are running a
business
you're lucky I'm not standing here with
a [__] writ on your ass about being
food poisoned
I've never done that before close down a
restaurant but that was a [__]
nightmare please get open
close the [__] place
[Music]
thank you
after spending 24 hours cleaning
what a difference you've got your
kitchen back to where it should be yeah
it's now day four and if there's any
hope of relaunching the restaurant
Gordon has to get through to the chefs
all right Doug we'll do a quick special
for tonight yes I'm just gonna do a pan
seared so with some crushing potatoes
it's time for this seafood restaurant to
put fresh fish back on the menu Tomatoes
bang just makes it a little bit more
vibrant yeah I've been doing this for 38
years I'm not happy at all I think he
needs to back off that's beautiful let's
come down to the point where I really
don't listen anymore let him do what he
wants
fresh and fragrant okay can we take you
through I want Peter yeah and I need to
taste it yes
[Music]
Irene I want you to taste that first I
want you to taste it as well so it's a
fresh vibrant tomato sauce
it's very good it's awesome
you don't want to taste no I'm good
I understood that no I'm good thank you
I didn't try the fish that Gordon had
made
because I I basically know what striped
bass tastes like if you are a chef the
38 years experience just tell me why you
didn't want to taste that
I know what Stripes tastes like and I'm
familiar with this Doug one more chance
you sure you don't want to taste that
positive
have the courtesy of trying God that's
the first time a guy's never tasted my
food
now I'm seriously insulted
[Music]
now that Gordon has shown them how to
make the special it's time to see Doug
and Charlie in action okay good off we
go I don't expect my cooking to be like
his announcement my best and to be like
his at this point I don't really want to
be here
[Music]
Charlie
what the [__] is this can he not cook a
piece of fish
Chef Ramsey you guys won't ever listen
to what he had to say again the fish is
cooked to [__] there's [__] and piss all
over the place oh yeah whatever
[Music]
it's an attempt to call yourself chefs
you know that [__] the four-star Chef
[__]
um [__] believable I am so pissed off
I sous chef they can't cook fish and his
chefs are just moping around doesn't
care this is a joke
I've seen all I need to see your head
chef is lazy dirty and he shouldn't be
anywhere near a kitchen
he's destroying your business quicker
than you can [__] realize
he'd be bothered to taste what I'd
cooked in 21 years of cooking that is a
first for me you asked me to come here
to work and fix your [__] business
I can't do it with those two Schmucks in
there
[Music]
you have got to make the biggest
decision you've ever made
since your father passed away whether
you whether you continue to work with
the dead wood that have drifted into
your business
or whether you wake up get a [__] and be
the boss
the one thing that I need you to carry
out for me
I want you to go in the kitchen and ask
Doug
and Charles to take it off
[Music]
Doug got you comfortable in being lazy
there's no excuse for that
decision is yours
[Music]
[Applause]
and I realized at that moment that
something had to be done
do you agree with me 100
Irene how does that sound to you that's
what is horrible fire them fire them in
a spot
that's what I want to hear that's what
he wants to hear they're not good enough
for this place
guys both off tomorrow are we done here
together
you sure
yes
I kind of expected it from the way that
we work tonight so am I a little upset
about you I'm a little bit upset
[Music]
right now I'm humiliated it's just
freaking hard it's hard
[Music]
it's now day five and the Seascape is
still closed before Gordon can solve the
chef crisis he has to light a fire under
Peter so this exercise is a way that you
let go release and let go yes you need
that right now release the tension okay
good get in the [__] ring
come on
I don't know what's happened but the
last three or four punches have been
stronger and stronger because I realize
how much of an ass I was in what way
you've been honest with me uh
I can't lie to you
[Music]
I knew my kitchen was dirty
I did what I've been doing my whole life
keeping the peace and keeping myself
down you've got no reason to keep
yourself down Peter oh my flop
never gave me a company told me I sucked
never could do nothing with my life
who's a great worker yeah but didn't
give a [__] about his own son who cared
about him
I'd let it destroy me he died before I
could prove him wrong you're doing that
now
proven [__] wrong you're right let's
go
I blame my father for my failures and it
was myself can't blame him no more come
on come on
finally
how do we get this gym in the restaurant
[Music]
while Gordon was having a breakthrough
with Peter his design team was
remodeling the restaurant
hello hello welcome come in come in come
in please Irene come through oh my God
oh my God the killer Irene I love it I
love it
[Music]
the red definitely doesn't look how warm
it is
new wood
it's absolutely gorgeous we definitely
needed to change and thank God Chef
Ramsey you did it all you brought
exactly the whole she escaped back even
the bar stool
gives it back the old Seascape Chong
why'd you say it full of people it is
gorgeous Marilyn how do you feel my
darling because this must go back in
time for you I can't believe the change
can you I'm overwhelmed I really am look
at your pictures Miss and to see my
picture up on the wall makes me feel
really good that I am maybe part of the
history of this restaurant I might even
cry
it looks almost like the old Seascape
but it has been brought back to life
definitely I think it's wonderful I
really do
and Peter and ladies tonight is the most
important night in the history of
Seascape tonight we're relaunching I am
so thrilled I am so thankful I never
expected this never I'm still dreaming
I'm still dreaming with the staff
reinvigorated by the new Decor the focus
now goes to the kitchen
after scouring the local community
Gordon has found a new head chef to
replace Doug got the bull by the horns
and [__] you know go for it yes and
with only hours until relaunch it's
straight to work preparing the new menu
okay this Martin basil sauce the idea
behind this is just giving it a little
bit of Vibrance nice clean fresh flavor
yeah a little bit of Basil
don't rush get you find your feet yeah
I'm fine no I can see if you're nervous
[Music]
okay good we've involved some of the old
classics from Seascape and put a modern
interpretation on them okay let's get
through it together fresh homemade crab
cake fresh pesto salmon Clams Casino
fried calamari surf and turf okay any
questions where's the fork
all around it's a great menu God must
have sent them I love this stuff with
the new menu and Decor all in order the
next step was to turn Peter into a
proper Major D
paptis runs my restaurant in New York
okay his parents are from Leona and he
grew up in restaurants okay and I want
him to spend some quality time now and
just sort of grooming you you're now
getting polished
first thing is how do you feel about
wearing jackets
too stiff maybe we can get one for
tonight don't you think I'm not the most
fashioned Savvy guy around
um show me how you walk around tables a
nice flowing motion
was everything right so far this is you
walking
that's every time I see you he's like
running around like a [__] baby
rhinoceros trying to have a [__]
can you just walk nice and slowly put
your shoulders back
nice and slow
there you go there look nice and again
lovely
[Music]
actually it's gonna be two seven tops
over here
I gotta prove myself to everybody the
town of Islip uh to myself to my
employees to my mother to my father
I just want 36 with you it's a fight to
reestablish this place oh yeah I
understand that my dad passed away two
years ago
so there's no way I can talk to my
father
so I feel it's the close second
[Music]
be feeling nervous
last chance
[Music]
good
Ness
[Music]
okay new Decor new menu new chef and now
I hope a new boss speaking for the first
time in this guy's life he's got to step
up to the mark come out with a shadow of
his father and prove to his mother and
himself he's more capable of running
this business let me have the fun no no
the phone stays here because he doesn't
make it tonight he's gonna [__] sink
tonight is the beginning of the new
Seascape right before it is sweating I'm
looking at the bigger picture I gotta
prove to my father I can't control
what's going on completely new menu I'll
have the uh Clams Casino I'm having the
seared straight back
thank you very much the wait staff is
revitalized by the influx of customers
and the new attitude at the Seascape
table five fire please first ten tables
are here um atmosphere is electric it
smells like a preparation Peter now has
to get a grip understand what's going on
and host the room we're looking at
probably about a 20 minute wait 100
customers are coming at us and coming at
us hard we were swamped how are we going
to see those people and how long how
long time they're gonna wait
now you start to be messy yeah excuse me
no it's missing so far
I think he's not going that well to be
honest try Peter this is where we need
to step up again now come on we're going
to step up big time let's go huh
with the restaurant packed the new chef
and the veteran waitresses are about to
be put to the test everybody keeps
taking food out of here
she wanted me to take I'm really pissed
off right now I'm gonna have a heart
attack These Girls Aren't used to being
[__] busy
really critical that a manager starts
running his bloody dining room because
Peter's restaurant is now in the ship
order's getting backed up the service is
starting to become slow kitchen's
falling behind petan he's gonna start
cracking the whip the kitchen is so
backed up I'm so sorry it's coming babe
it's coming it's hoping everything will
go so perfect and it just not the food's
just not coming out I've been waiting
for the entrees it's like six o'clock 6
30. what's the matter my two kids still
haven't eaten and what were they getting
what were they getting certain muscles
muscles are an appetite okay awesome
oh Skye what Table Three did not get
their appetizers I mean they only been
here since [__] 6 30. that's gonna
that goes on the back of the line that
you gotta wait hold on let's get one
thing done I fighted a long time ago and
no no when you fired it it still goes on
the back of the line Peter the wait
staff here they're two set in their ways
oh Scott when I go with the French on
you automatically make them for me right
there's no one telling them what they
can and can't do they're just coming in
they're taking what they want they're
just grabbing food is that yours or mine
Diane this is mine it's very frustrating
I can't communicate when this is too
stupid making sure the front of the
house is in sync with the kitchen is
Peter's responsibility and Irene is
losing her patience because he's not
stepping up and taking control hey
somebody pick up this food my apologies
I'm sorry
now what do you want what are you doing
I can't believe this hasn't gone out wow
what do you want mom killing me brother
take charge mom you know how to rip into
me for two days saying I'm never gonna
grow up shut the [__] up well this is
why I never grow up mom you are the boss
start acting like one take charge don't
do this [__] mom take charge all the
little things mushroomed into a big
thing I'm sorry we're trying the best we
can
that just walked out can you find out
where Peter is and ask me what the [__]
he's doing please yeah Peter
doing Peter
I'm ready to give up my raise
again
my father right now is turning over in
his grave
[Music]
it's the big relaunch of the Seascape
and the restaurant is at full capacity
but with the front of the house not
communicating with the kitchens way too
many people touching food in this
kitchen my apologies I'm sorry Peter is
losing control Pizza I need two seconds
with you
I really want you to [__] shine
tonight you've got no idea take control
when you're not happy with certain
things get it off your [__] chest
think back to the boxing ring yes
I'm just asking you to run yourself
Gordon is 100 writer tonight I gotta
prove to myself to my employees to my
mother that I'm willing to take a
challenge and be advice you can do it
okay for one favor of course you can can
I have a hug a hug why not here we go
let's go let's do it tonight let's go
hey
yes we got it I'll try to stand up
straight okay all right guys we're
starting it up I know what has to get
done I might piss some people off but
sorry we gotta get it done right you're
making a plan right now okay take this
off okay there we go we make a new one
right at a critical time in the night
Gordon's pep talk has finally inspired
Peter
yes John Baptiste to go back into the
kitchen and try and expedite the food to
make the food go out faster so we can
sit the people down just to me they take
the order and give it a new number and
explain it to John Baptiste what it is
now you can talk to Marilyn while she's
here yeah and I'll find out from Diane
it's what they call improvising good
it's your four top now I'm gonna get her
three top here you had gotten the bar
table right yes thank you okay here we
go finally
you're on a roll Marilyn you're on a
roll baby I felt like I was back when I
first opened up when the passion was
still here we were moving and grew it
finally got everything under control the
flounder is just
out of this world
considering where the Seascape was just
days ago the reopening was a success
please take a seat down yes okay what a
nice it was only just literally a few
days ago that this place was closed we
met the chef today for the first time to
put that standard out job well done
finally I feel Peter actually took
charge so I'm really really happy we
know where to work at it did you get a
better yes but for me I know damn well
customers tonight will come back yes you
have to seriously continue running your
business yes
as the week progressed Gordon worked
with the new Chef to come up with a
vibrant new menu making sure to
introduce fresh produce from the local
vendors you are the luckiest owner in
the world to have this boat in your
backyard yeah I'm telling you then to
endear the restaurant back into the
community Gordon created an annual
chowder cook-off that was judged by the
town mayor ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the Seascape
I quite like that little burning
sensation the back of my throat it's
good different the winner Joe barini
[Applause]
please come back and taste it on the
menu for dinner Scott the new Chef
whipped the kitchen into shape you're
not doing that table first this one
right here please I'm sorry order your
crab cake two oysters and Marilyn
brought back one of seascape's old
traditions tableside flambe
[Music]
the place was alive and everybody was
smiling is it lovely
if you've got some room don't be scared
to ask for more yes last but not least a
new respect has been established by a
mother for her son all right Mom let's
start it up okay we have a party of six
that they call
[Music]
okay so you're leaving us tonight yes
it is amazing what he did he taught me
to stand up and be the owner
love and support yes
take care thank you thank you for
everything not a soup stand strong buddy
yes I will up
yeah I got it one two three I got it I
feel very grateful to Chef Ramsay I will
never forget what the man did he put his
heart and soul into this place he did
save us
even though Gordon successfully restored
the Seascape to its former glory Peter
accepted an offer that he couldn't
refuse and sold the restaurant for the
last three years Chef Ramsay has whipped
aspiring chefs into shape on Hell's
Kitchen this is painful get out out now
Gordon Ramsay the most successful
restaurateur on the planet with
critically acclaimed restaurants in
London Dubai Tokyo and New York is
crisscrossing America for the most
difficult assignment of his career this
is disgusting I am gobsmacked turning
around America's Kitchen Nightmares
please help me
each week he will go to restaurants on
the brink of disaster there is no more
money he's not doing his job this place
is a disaster Zone I put so much into it
but to get these restaurants back on
track Chef Ramsay will hold nothing back
I've never ever ever
met someone
I believe in as little as you
it will be intense
Pig
crap I'd rather have this conversation
downstairs it will be emotional
that's it seriously I'm pissed off it's
not my fault why did you keep beating if
it was that bad
and it will be shocking try them on a
spot oh my God look at them it's [__]
rancid it's rotten I've eaten it I've
been like spitting out both of them I
think this place will run better without
you can you go and tell them that the
kitchen is closed we're shut it's the
luckiest day of their lives
for the night
we will make this a success put your
hand up to swear to God in the end you
will see dramatic turnarounds aren't
they horrible
[Music]
of not just the restaurants
oh it's fantastic but the people who
work in them I'll never forget you man
the best of my life bro you're the best
man and while most appreciate his health
God bless you you are a wonderful person
others aren't so grateful
Jeff I know you can hear me don't run
what is this guy here who the [__] are
you to turn around and tell me when you
were like a pig you French Pig goodbye
Chef good luck loser
get ready as Chef Ramsay turns America's
Kitchen Nightmares gonna go four guys
received may the Lord not kill me with
food poisoning back into dreams please
do not screw it up
tonight Gordon faces an overwhelming
challenge it's time to walk away there's
nothing else to do the mixing bowls
business is dwindling and relationships
are crumbling can't get so overwhelmed I
wasn't told why you keep saying that I'm
pissed off the manager is desperate I've
tried everything the owner has lost his
passion you look like a man that's dying
to be put out of his misery and his wife
wants him to shut the place down I can't
sacrifice myself for the mixing bowl
anymore now Gordon must turn the mixing
bowl upside down fighting for my life
it's the last chance for this dying
restaurant
Kitchen Nightmare
nightmare
[Music]
Bellmore New York a busy commuter town
about 30 minutes from New York City and
home to a wide variety of restaurants
for 10 years The Mixing Bowl has managed
to survive but now with increased
competition it's only months away from
closing they said Cajun not Asian
my name is Billy galetti I'm the chef
owner of The Mixing Bowl pick it up I'm
the Chef Delivery guy Mr Fix It doing
bills picking up supplies I'm off the
floors if I have to it's what I have to
do to keep the place alive
The Mixing Bowl Eatery has been here for
10 years Lisa is this order right you
know what you're supposed to be a
manager not your wife if it was up to
Billy's wife the restaurant would be
closed next week it says two muscles
should say one my hope is really gone
for this place
how bad was it yesterday disaster six
people came in the restaurant all night
last night everyone just knows he's
mixing ball Mike right this way young
ladies yes he's the manager but it's
impossible to work with him you'll get
five times more pay than his
kind of like one big happy family what
you just said makes absolutely no sense
that doesn't make sense shut up
Mike what are you doing taking a drink
is on parched he is the manager
what does Mike do now
oh
[Music]
I see him schmooze a lot
yes people come in here and they think
I'm the owner they call me like the
mayor of Belmore do they do that because
they respect me they fear me I don't
know shut up and let me finish talking
nobody's gonna listen to someone who's
yelling at them like a madman talking to
you was like talking to a brick wall all
right all right all right
when The Mixing Bowl first opened it was
busy every week you know it was really
doing well [__] the people man
now it's just slow
everybody's like depressed
we tried everything that we can there is
no more money
there
isn't nothing else to do if something
doesn't change and someone doesn't help
us out the restaurant could be closed
next week now it's at the end of the raw
I'm so stubborn about keeping it alive
but am I hurting myself am I hurting my
family you're holding everything up now
with all this crap I'm sorry that's what
I wrote our marriage gets affected by
his business go go out go out we're
struggling seven days a week that puts a
damper on our relationship I can't
sacrifice myself and our children for
The Mixing Bowl anymore
if it's not going to work it's time to
walk away
Gordon Ramsay has just one week to
uncover the restaurant's problems devise
a plan and find a way for this
restaurant to stand out in this
competitive market I'm nervous because
this looks Dreadful
[Music]
oh my God it's a pleasure to have you
here sorry Gordon my first name Michael
Anderson Mike nice to see you it's
exciting just like oh my God I'm meeting
Gordon Ramsay you know to me if he's a
God in the restaurant industry
Lisa nice to see you
God
well this is quiet
this is typical staff one two three four
how many book for lunch nobody no when
Gordon first came in I was nervous and I
hope it's just not too hard on all of us
I'm gonna sit here yes this is the lunch
menu and what style of restaurant is it
it's new American type Cuisine salads
some wraps a little bit of pasta like a
health spa
um where when was the last time you went
to a spa
Jim
what was the last time you went to the
gym
uh not for a long time when was the last
time we had a salad not for a long time
right okay if you have any questions
please feel free to ask okay great
when you look at the way the Russians
put together you can identify instantly
from the paper cloth to the drapes to
the plants the ceiling to the color that
this restaurant really is on its last
legs there's not long to go here
[Music]
award-winning Maryland lump crab cakes
said North Atlantic salmon sun-dried
tomato basil for such a small ration the
menus are huge
maybe a couple of minutes I'm dying to
taste their award-winning Marathon crab
case they are excellent an award-winning
what do they win
you could ask Billy he knows more about
it I thought you'd know about it if
you're the manager and it's on your menu
well I anyway I I have a zucchini
pancake okay and I'll go for the say the
North Atlantic salmon I think
thank you
God that guy needs some spark bean bag
he is intimidating to serve
okay these are the Maryland crab cakes
thank you and zucchini pancakes with
chives love it thank you enjoy thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much
I'm all running maybe not in terms of
freshness yeah I wouldn't expect to find
something so fresh for such a dreary
Dreadful dining room
zucchini pancakes stodgy Bland and it's
pretty thick
it's like having a mouthful of blue
[Music]
oh my God what's that on Top Tomato
Basil balsamic
there's no garlic where's the garlic
from is that on the green beans the
shallots no garlic in any of the
ingredients and then on the beans looks
like there's garlic in there why don't
you just check with him I can smell it
anyway I will that looks like garlic
thank you Billy what the string beans
you cook them in garlic
is there any shallots in there at all no
shells
someone by glands and sauce just heavy
soggy and vinegary
garlic everywhere no one wants to come
out to lunch and stink of garlic that's
for sure you know Billy's getting a
little nervous like am I about to get
Reams right now you know
[Music]
I don't know what to expect to be honest
when you first walk in that dining room
you get this depressing manager jumping
on you which is a great shame
I'm sure five years ago you had some
form of spark the food the crab cakes
were good thanks yes that was the high
point everything else unfortunately for
me just planned
pancakes are soggy and fish was dry the
salmon just it just looked old-fashioned
ask you an honest question yes it was
our 10 year anniversary
everybody gets complimentary pants now
everybody tells me they love them if you
give something away and it's free who's
gonna complain about it
that never happens so either he's crazy
or every customer comes in here is lying
to me want to come back with a plan and
bang it didn't blow me away today I'm
not that excited about it it's very
average very dreary and it's very sad
end of story
okay see you later yes it makes me feel
terrible when Gordon says he doesn't
like my husband's food you know of
course I'm going to take the fence to
that Gordon is wrong about the
restaurant my position is the manager so
I am not intimidated by anybody bring it
on
coming up Gordon sees a sign of the
times now accepting dinner reservations
we thought maybe because we're not
taking reservations so it's [__]
empty Lisa and Billy must face the truth
maybe we should close this place down
and later as Gordon turns up the heat
and you wake up manager Mike loses seven
o'clock this morning that okay seriously
I'm pissed off do not talk to me like
that
hey [__] off outside now he's a freaking
lunatic coming up on Kitchen Nightmares
later that night after meeting the staff
and sampling the food Gordon wants to
observe a dinner service so he can
evaluate Billy in the kitchen and Mike
in the front of the house
two or three people
Jesus this is not very good right now it
is seven o'clock and there's a lot of
open tables in the restaurant
to me I would have shut the doors a year
ago wherever you feel like it's your
trip why not
it's an hour into the dinner service and
it's starting to become clear to Gordon
why the mixing bowl is losing so much
money this coupon you could use it this
evening
50 off yeah check is all adjusted thank
you very much thank you
I'm taking 50 off my check we hand
somebody a check you put this 50 off
coupon in it
in here yeah 50 off holy smoke so we're
giving more money away before we get
money in the till my goodness me
Jesus
Christ just told me about a true partner
he tried I
have years eight years Christ that
doesn't make sense that does it no it
doesn't
do you ever go out there
um
[Music]
while Billy spends the entire dinner
service in the kitchen the
responsibility of running the restaurant
is in Mike's hands any more coupons
anywhere else no no that's for sure
nothing at all
there is more I have about 10 signs that
I had made up
go and get them
[Music]
someone grab the door for me please
sorry
[Music]
all of them go in the window at some
point where did you get all these from I
have a place they make them up for me it
was expensive holy mackerel as you can
see I tried everything
Clearly Now accepting preservations
maybe because we're not taking
reservations maybe people aren't coming
in here
it's empty yes but it was it [__]
empty Tuesday night dinner specials
select three three one that was that was
one of the worst things we've ever done
um so we did uh select three it was it
was a while ago we did um and that's the
pumpkin what kind of can I can I tell
you what because listen read this order
your Thanksgiving desserts early yes in
case we're closed by the time we come
round to November what I do is I I'll
put up a sign a month ahead of time
because maybe people will drive by and
say oh look which sign was the most
successful
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
can you come here it's a little big what
in the [__] free appetizer with dinner
um get me out of here
Jesus Christ
[Music]
it went over it went over the you saw
these other little signs weren't working
and how long did the sign go for well it
would have still been up but there was a
a bad Windstorm a few months ago and it
ripped it down it blew the signs down
yes thanks [__] for that doesn't this
catch your eye though from the street
catch more oh isn't that the point it's
[__] worse than the dollar shop
you're incredible okay get the signs and
put them back around here I don't want
any customers to see it
I've got a Russian tour it's just a cook
a simple cook a manager totally obsessed
by signs and a wife I'd rather close the
place down tonight this is a real
nightmare my God
after a day of observation Gordon is
ready to confront Billy and Lisa with
the harsh reality
I've got to be [__] brutally honest
with you you know that I've seen a lot
today watch the service
unfortunately I spent a lot of time
talking to Mike and uh yeah he's uh he's
out there that one
you seriously have to start thinking as
a businessman not leaving it to someone
like Michael to sort of focus on the
baloney and [__] and then watching
you cooking I've never ever seen a chef
so quiet in all my life
you look like a man that's dying to be
put out of his misery Lisa you may be
right
to put you out your misery maybe we
should close this place down [__] me
tonight
[Music]
up next there is Mutiny at The Mixing
Bowl I think he's lazy the rest of us
bust our butts to get your tables and
our tables done and then you take a half
like of our test do you think you would
have those tips if I wasn't here and
later before Billy steps up I was told
seven o'clock this morning that's it
seriously I'm pissed off I don't want
him to talk to my wife that way
like that Gordon steps in you [__] off
outside now
[Music]
coming up on Kitchen Nightmares
after the dinner service Gordon decides
to test Billy and Lisa's commitment to
the restaurant Lisa you may be right
to put you out your misery maybe we
should close this place down [__]
tonight
the stress and the pressure relieved
bang be gone within 12 hours
so what is it
I don't want him to give up his dream
but I don't see why we keep going with
it Billy's a good person he doesn't want
to just walk away but if he has to close
the doors it needs to be closed then and
let's move on already I want to live a
normal life
this is where you really seriously
dig deep
if the restaurant dies it'll be like a
death in the family we have to go
forward let me turn this around
seriously yeah
if you seriously seriously want to
continue you have got to find your
passion with your support and truthfully
unless you change you'll be gone in six
weeks time
[Music]
it's day two and time for Gordon to
start implementing his plan he hopes to
get through to manager Mike about his
destructive promotions with the help of
a somewhat destructive measure
looks like a wood chipper to me that's
right it's time to say goodbye to the
Past It's Time to Say Goodbye to
Valentine's Day
okay
[Music]
you're mad man yeah I am [__] mad
working guys like you makes me [__]
mad
with Gordon struggling to get through to
Mike he now turns his attention to the
mixing Bowl's greatest challenge
1997 first
one two three four restaurants wow yeah
10 years ago let me show you something
2007.
holy [__] so look how built up this
neighborhood's become over the last 10
years 41 restaurants from a Chinese to a
deli to a pizza to a diner right now we
need to reposition The Mixing Bowl smack
bang in the middle of all that
competition Gordon's right 41
restaurants of course you're going to
kind of get lost in the shuffle what
else is around this area you go to it
every day oh the gym gyms Beauty parlors
tanning salon what isn't on there
something that's not even listed
anywhere near here one way we can help
turn this around is by installing
something to do with health
exciting to realize you can do things
healthy and just open my eyes to A Whole
New World give the [__] neighborhood
what they want
with the mixing bowl now embracing being
the healthy high quality restaurant of
Belmore Gordon also realizes he needs to
ignite Billy's passion time to be
competitive creative yeah our list of 15
ingredients okay half an hour you work
there I work there keep it fresh and
healthy think about the direction of the
restaurant the way it's going yes okay
Gordon Ramsay teaching Billy he's being
trained by one of the top chefs in the
world
I was totally into what I was doing but
then like you realize that's Gordon
Ramsay working next to you here it was
great so you shredded the fennel same
way I've shredded it I hope you're not
copying me Billy man
you're copying me oh dear I was so
excited because I haven't seen Billy
this fired up about something in so long
you're very quiet there my man [__] you
know what is it with you you must drive
Lisa around the bend you know that how
did you communicate through email I
wasn't paying attention to what he was
doing at all I was more involved in just
making my dish let's go my man
[Music]
by the way
will he finish first
okay good so yours is a seared salmon
with ginger balsamic drizzle this is a
poached salmon uh just poaching the
vegetable stock top with a walnut pesto
everything looked really nice just fresh
and Lively and vibrant and the food kind
of like jumped out of you look great
this is the kind of food that The Mixing
Bowl should be serving I like that both
dishes are good enough to go on the menu
tonight I like the food but I really
don't know if Gordon can change this
place around
[Music]
the word that world-class Chef Ramsay is
in town the mixing bowl is busier than
normal for tonight's dinner service we
have reservations this evening
but can the staff at The Mixing Bowl
actually cope with a busy Restaurant
special yeah I think that the customer
is absolutely going to love the new
salmon dish
we're running a restaurant not a [__]
zoo
[Music]
did you get the salmon special okay good
let's take 12 hours do you like salmon
yeah I would try salmon three salmon
specials good we're selling the salmon
good
they don't particularly care about the
kitchen your main focus should be the
customers the water is complementary is
he working out all he does is stand and
talk and lean and pray
summer specials really going well but
Michael what the [__] is he doing this
guy is just [__] using this question
to feed his ego but I'm glad you guys
are enjoying everything you want your
friends to come in that's great but you
should be out working yeah
it's impossible to work with him and
every time you work with him he takes
half of your tips Kimmy you gotta work
the tips baby I get very large tips give
them some more watering table 18 please
I mean 20 25 could you do you have to
put on another round of drinks another
bottle another bud and another Diet Coke
also I'm tired of Mike taking half the
money from the tip cup that's not fair
goodbye thank you
[Applause]
despite the success of the new specials
the staff is unhappy with their tips and
all fingers are pointing toward Mike you
find a table you latch on and then the
rest of us bust our butts to get your
tables and our tables done and then you
take a half like of our test can I can I
say something
do you think you would have those tips
if I wasn't here
when people come in here everybody knows
me the customers know me and all you
guys know that people know me the best
because I make it a point of making
friends with customers and that's what
customers want they want to feel special
Mike thinks this is his restaurant he is
an employee here [__] unbelievable
okay time to get real when I ask you to
wake up in terms of running the [__]
business sometimes you run it as if you
own the place and the reason why you do
that is because Billy you are too weak
and at least if it sounds crap open up
and say it I was nervous that
everybody's sitting here with their
thumbs up their asses and they're doing
what they're supposed to be doing I
don't think right now that's the right
attitude I think we should have a
positive attitude I mean be realistic
when I'm busting my own tables and
everybody else is running around crazy
we are aware of what the problems were
and I think that we should move forward
and put the damn pass behind us you're
kind of talking to yourself right now
I'm talking this is how I feel these are
things you need to do
I I'm fighting for my life here
[Music]
you right now need to step up to the
plate and make the changes every
freaking day every minute of the day
that's it
Billy that's the first time
you sounded like a boss
because it's your [__] life on the
line don't ever forget that hey he's
laughing again if you're carrying the
weight that this guy Andy's wife has on
their shoulders you wouldn't [__]
smoke
[Music]
tomorrow the most important day in 10
years we're going to implement changes
to help get this business turned around
if this doesn't work after tomorrow the
blame
is on your shoulders Mike
still to come
ball is
coming now you [__] hell that was
just fed up but nobody is in the mood
for celebrating it I was told seven
o'clock this morning that's it it's the
dinner service you have to see to
believe seriously I'm pissed off
to me like that
coming up on Kitchen Nightmares
day three
Gordon's Design Team Works overnight and
transforms the mixing bowl from a
non-descript diner into a contemporary
Sleek restaurant and now it's time to be
revealed right ready yes Mike ready
so excited to see like what you know
[Music]
place needs a facelift so I'm very
excited to see it nice guy lovely
here we go
oh my God
it's gorgeous
Jesus yes
no kissing huh
it looks nice ah beautiful this is
gorgeous
I feel like I want to spend money in
here
exciting to walk out to the dining room
and just seeing what it looks like
the decor was terrible now I think the
decor works it fits with the food it
fits with the name Lisa what do you
think of the chairs
[Music]
it's beautiful wall oh my God
it's amazing it just was like a gift it
was just like a period of Grace it
really touched me deeply it looks like a
restaurant now doesn't it yes are you
serious gonna start spending time in
your own restaurant now you're saying
hello to customers yep Kim how do you
feel darling it looks completely
different I feel so much better about
coming here knowing that they're not
looking around thinking why am I sitting
here with this gross paper on my table
[Music]
gorgeous I can't wait for customers to
come
[Music]
sorry I can't wait for customers to come
in and see the place Jesus Lisa we got
any tissues hey
[Music]
this is our new start so hopefully it's
what we needed it's unbelievable
[Music]
with the new Decor as the inspiration
it's time for Gordon to overhaul the
menu okay first salad apple and undies
um salad yes and it's done with walnuts
and a honey Dijon dressing very fresh
fragrant very citrusy very Tangy Gordon
woke me up he got me back to what's now
and just trying to put that together
under Gordon's Direction The Mixing Bowl
has removed heavily Sauced entrees and
replaced them with healthy vibrant items
roasting fine tomato soup slow roasted
in the oven overnight Blended and it's
finished with fresh basil and drizzled
olive oil tuna nisswas it's been dressed
with an olive tapenade green beans
olives eggs and roasted new potatoes
there we got to see the way all the new
dishes looked they looked beautiful
smaller portions lighter Foods all of it
made sense good right are we ready yeah
yes good luck I love the menu because I
was eating all the food in here so now
I'm eating a little bit healthier it may
uh may have an impact on my uh always
with a healthy new menu and the
restaurant redesign it's time to utilize
the staff's new energy and spread the
word about the new mixing bowl we'll go
out to a spa or gym we'll just put the
word out fresh Outlook fresh appeal oh
my God look at these hi guys you all
know what the mixing bowl is right
that's the Russian there in The Mixing
Bowl we're going to be kicking off our
new light vibrant healthy menu exciting
new food it'd be great to see at the
mixing bowl Eatery in Belmar New Decor
new menu new style yes Gordon Gordon I'm
burning 1700 calories per hour if Billy
could see you right now not bad for a
fat guy huh
I brought you here for a wake-up call
yeah let's go Oh in keeping with the
healthy direction of the restaurant
Gordon has reached out to the New York
dragons Arena Football team to create
some buzz in the community
big day for us tomorrow so we want to
help celebrate that and uh maybe get you
down to the restaurant and come have a
bite to eat I think it's an amazing idea
foreign
only a short time before relaunch and
Mike is already feeling the heat there's
a couple of little tiny things that
bother me because I want I want the
place to look perfect next thing about
Mike speaking can I help you how many
people are you gonna be there was a lot
of confusion with the reservations and
there was a lot of things that I really
had to do myself disgusting he's having
a hard time today which we all were you
know but he really lost it actually all
right
we need Xanax light just seemed so
stressed and I was definitely concerned
that it wasn't going to help us when we
opened the doors that's it
that's it
[Music]
with the relaunch only minutes away
everything seems to be in place for the
big night
looks like we have 47 and the restaurant
is fully booked
good luck yes let's go big boy
Customs are cue not to get here Jesus
Christ
unfortunately there were too many
reservations set at the same time oh no
even I'm getting a little bit [__]
dulali there'll be a van picking me up
in a minute with a [__] stray jacket
I was not tired
[__] Madness
[Music]
it's the mixing Bowl's biggest night and
because of Mike's reservations mix up
many of the customers have arrived at
the same time how you doing how's
everything as soon as those doors open
and the floodgates opened up and
everyone kind of came at once it was a
little bit stressful just give me two
seconds Mike yeah right come over coming
okay reservations what's the hiccup
I handed over the reservation list to
Kim and then I'm not exactly sure what
transpired since then Mike trying to
blame the reservation mix up on me
I've never been the one in charge of the
reservations it's not fair
this is a big night I cannot tell you
how big this big this night is and
you've got to know what's coming in
that's your job it's not solely my fault
and I don't think that it's right to put
blame on any one person can we get on
yes and work as a team yes God
after Gordon's pep talk Lynn Kim and
Lisa all stepped in to help get everyone
seated
totally different menu
okay with the dining room now completely
full for the first time in years the
pressure was turned up on The Mixing
Bowl staff Mike do you have table five
not even there at least
let me try that for you please thank you
can you wake up wake up this is our one
shot to make our Lasting Impression
we're gonna blow it how low on the
appetizers you can't drive me crazy
right now honestly I think Mike's job's
not that hard
he just gets sidetracked and stops stops
being a manager
while each waiter is covering three to
four tables all right so let me go ahead
Mike is looking after his friends
can I get the three suits I need shoes
now yeah it's coming now you [__]
hell watch your back what's your back I
was definitely concerned that Mike was
gonna crumble he's not used to running a
[__] busy dining room out there you
know that yeah oh my God
where's mine
thank you
oh
my God
now
it's two hours into dinner service and
The Mixing Bowl has weathered the first
storm but they are about to be faced
with another challenge the New York
dragons
[Music]
Hi how are you you're gonna have a nice
dinner
okay so we're just gonna get your table
together okay all right we'll be right
with you
wait a minute I thought that that table
was going
can I see this
I forgot the biggest thing to put on the
list the dragon's reservation the
dragons were supposed to be on that list
and somehow Mike just forgot how is that
missed how is that feeling someone is
the dragon that's not what I'm saying
I'm not exactly sure what transpired
Beyond's upsetting there was no dragons
on there oh my God that table for me is
the most important table
that's embarrassing you're overlooking
extremely important thing
I was not told about the dragons I found
out why you keep saying that because I
wasn't I wasn't told
[Music]
excuse me do not
seven o'clock this morning
that's it seriously I'm pissed off
dragons on the paper
I'm pissed off
not my fault
dragons right over here I put them on at
seven o'clock can we please move on
that's it
not my fault
it's relaunch night for the mixing bowl
and Mike's reservation mishap with the
New York dragons has caused him to go
over the edge
I wasn't told do not talk to me like
that pissed off that's it I was told
seven o'clock this morning not my fault
dragons on the paper
I mean please move on that's it
flew all in shock and speechless
I've seen him blow up before but that
was a new there's a new level right
there hey yes can you [__] off outside
now
Jesus Christ
[Music]
this is like the Twilight Zone I really
think something in his brain has snapped
he's a freaking lunatic
[Music]
Mike was raising his voice I mean I
don't want him to talk to my wife that
way I don't go for that
Mike's conduct has everyone rattled and
Gordon has some concerns for the
restaurant owners
okay
let me just tell you something and I've
gotta be brutally honest you've got one
problem here
[Music]
Mike
I don't know why Billy and Lisa were
talking to Gordon I don't know what they
possibly could have said about me
you need a manager and that is not your
man
business is business if something's got
to be done to change in this place we
gotta change it that's the restaurant
business freaking firearm
[Music]
go home right now Life Goes On
I get another job
but my life would be different
I just gotta reevaluate the situation
[Music]
Mike's gonna have to change like the
place has changed so everybody else in
the place is gonna get a second chance
so it might shoot me a second chance and
we're gonna move forward together for
now Billy has decided to keep Mike on as
manager
move on yeah that was
embarrassing yeah can we put an end to
this I feel like I'm reborn again and we
are going to build the best damn
restaurant
that that
ever existed or at least in a 25 mile
radius all right table two is getting up
we're gonna push it together for a table
of four Mike managed to find a place to
seat the dragons and it looks like
Gordon has finally gotten through to it
ready set
I have a new New Look new restaurant New
Me music thank you so much I'm Gonna Get
You dinner out real quick all right good
job good job
for the first time he said thank you to
V
so that was like wow all of a sudden
you know like was that him that was
great services but excellent I give the
service yeah
although the mixing bowls relaunch had
some Growing Pains it's clear the
restaurant is headed in the right
direction
[Music]
as the week progressed
Mike's management skills kept improving
one and two is crucial that we get out
of here
the customers raved about the vibrant
food I love the new menu It's So
Different it feels right we got some
amazing feedback from the food Billy
everybody's really loving the food
[Music]
the prophets were soaring what each
person spends on average went up I like
double in the spirit of the new healthy
menu Gordon sponsored the first ever
mixing bowl mile run hello Mike come on
Mike an eight-year-old is beating you
and with the restaurant thriving Billy
even found some time to hang out with
his new friends the dragons this journey
was unbelievable I'm excited to go
forward that's what I want to say that
passion yes yep
and on Gordon's last day he even got shy
Billy to finally come out of the kitchen
how are you just stop what are you doing
for two minutes I go say hello to your
customers
I'm so proud of him I couldn't be more
proud of her I want him to get a little
recognition for all that he does
thank you so much
the difference tonight from when I first
arrived was extraordinary I would
seriously eat here he'll tell us this
big boy you've got to make a transition
from a chef to restaurant tour
I got the message on how I have to
change to make this place the best it
could be
thinking and cooking up there
not with your back
yes thank you so much the black cloud
has definitely been lifted off this
restaurant we can't blame anyone but
ourselves now because there's no excuses
left
ladies
it all came together and I just can't
wait to go forward good knife thank you
thank you
[Music]
two months have gone by and the
restaurant is continuing to prosper
Gordon he just let everything out on me
it was like rip on Mike week but he
definitely did teach me some things we
had fun with it as for Billy and Lisa
their marriage is as strong as the
restaurant itself the changes I've seen
in our relationship is amazing so for
that
Gordon I thank you that means so much to
me